you know we'd be remiss if we didn't
recognize the passing of of justice ruth
bader ginsburg oh man on friday night uh
let's go back to friday night man um
yeah just what was your
what was your immediate reaction i
imagine it was like a lot of us
yeah we got the news friday night
yeah uh immediate reaction i thought was
captured perfectly
uh
by kai
on the brother from another text chain
uh
when it was like expletive
rbg died
and and and i think we all felt that way
you know because she was
she was the perfect person for a time
such as this
you know some people some people might
some people can't handle power
or
some people when they when they reach a
position it's all about the achievement
it's about what they did but what i what
i really love about her and her career
consistently at every step
it was hey i'm doing this
i'm doing it because it's my passion i'm
doing it because i need to educate
people but beyond educating
we need to do some legislating and so
that was her her mission the entire way
and i'll tell you the inspiration there
are so many so many layers of
inspiration with brooklyn's finest rbg
and that is one
don't ever don't ever get a you know
young people don't ever get get upset if
you're not the first choice for the job
she was not the first she was not bill
clinton's first choice
uh for the supreme court back in 1993
she was the third choice
why was she the third choice he had two
people he had two men in mind
and there was there was some pressure
from her husband
to give her a shot so he had like a
campaign hey listen look at look at what
my wife has done because he knew how
brilliant she was and he had to fight
just so she could get an audience that's
one and the other thing i really love
about her is that she went there
and was always willing to say look
these are the these are the laws
i'm going to show you without beating
you over the head i'm going to show you
with my superior intellect
why this is unjust why it's sexist and
why you need to change it
six times i love it yeah i love her
record six times before she was on the
ground right yeah five and one
sounds like somebody else i have in mind
that sounds like thurgood marshall so
these are special people and and i'm
glad i'm glad that we have the
inspiration we have the example
of rbg to um
just to to use as
something man we all need something to
hang on to we need some hope
and she yeah
a lot a lot of people a lot of people
have uh said she you know approached the
battle for sex equality in much the same
way that thurgood marshall strategically
and legisl and legally excuse me and
ultimately
legislatively approach the um
battle for
um
for racial equality he said a lot there
a couple of things um
[Music]
just in terms of our strategy man
uh very calculated
um
you know took a lot of cases with men as
the plaintiffs
in order to establish precedent
uh as it relates to
sex equality by arguing on behalf of men
you know when when their situat you know
for when their cases challenge the
uh the sex and and gender standard of
the day what's also fascinating about
her
um
is that she didn't you know a lot of
people just have activism throwing
flowing through their veins and they
grow up
you know uh
questioning and and challenging the
status quo she wasn't like that i mean
she
she adhered to you know the standards of
her time early on it wasn't until later
in her life in her career when she got
with the aclu that she really started to
question and challenge and even later
when she found her voice
as a voice of dissent on the high court
and she became this pop culture icon
what notorious rbg well into her 80s so
the inspiration there for me at least is
like you know you could think like oh
what have i done with my life when you
still got you know you gotta you gotta
you may have a long way to go and it may
be you know something later in life for
you to accomplish that you have that
that you don't even realize and even to
your point about her not being clinton's
first choice
um there were a lot of women who weren't
so sure
that she was really all in on that
movement because she questioned the
strategy behind roe v wade not the
substance of it but the strategy behind
roe v wade and so
you know it's just just a life
well-lived and and the sad part about it
i mean her last wish
you know was that you know her seat not
be filled until a new president is
elected the sad part about and i asked
you about your reaction is that
everybody
we couldn't
sh
she we couldn't mourn her properly and
everybody tried to do two things over
the weekend
recognize her appreciate her celebrate
her
uh if you didn't know a lot about her
educate her
about the same token it's
like well you know what i mean it was
like really like on top of all the other
stuff we got going on because you know
they're going to try to ram one last
well you know hopefully last but
one last justice really tilt the balance
of power uh in the high court before
this election uh and if if trump were to
succeed first of all the average
confirmation time has been 70 days since
1975 if in fact he shows
some
modicum of dec decency and waits until
her services to announce uh
his his selection on friday that'd be 39
days
until the election
but if he succeeds and mcconnell avoids
having
you know another
two or three republicans
flip on him and mcconnell's able to
actually you know keep that majority
when it comes to confirmation
trump will be the first president i
believe since reagan
to confirm three judges on the supreme
court which obviously has generational
ramifications on the bright side
hopefully what this does we talked last
week about and i think you asked why is
it going to be so complicated when it
comes to
you know voters
uh yeah
choosing joe biden you know seems to be
the obvious choice for most reasonable
people maybe this is the thing because
a lot of republicans their deal with the
devil
or their deal with the devil incarnate
was just judges judges and justices they
wanted the courts and he's done his job
by that term it has been a successful
term for donald trump maybe this is the
thing
that galvanizes
democratic voters because the question
and our boy jason johnson wrote this on
the grio the question is and i've said
this before the question is not
whether people are going to vote for
donald trump or joe biden it's whether
you're going to vote or not as strange
as that sounds maybe this is the thing
that galvanizes voters in particular
young voters who may otherwise not be
too enthused about the democratic ticket
for whatever reason maybe that's the
thing that gets people out and got out
into the polls
i'll i'll tell you um
no matter no matter and i i keep i keep
finding myself saying this
but i believe it
no matter where you stand politically
you cannot look at this life well-lived
yeah of rbg you cannot look at this
courageous this courageous life this
life of i i'm gonna dissent
and i'm going to tell you why and it's
going to make sense it's going to be
smart and it's going to move you to
action so that's who she was
so
you can't look at this life
celebrate it say how great she was and
then go back to the way you were
i can't and i'm not in politics
but if you are if you are in politics
and you're talking about how great she
is and then you just go to default mode
then i think you've missed the
the whole thing you missed the whole
thing
look she was that one thing you cannot
say
about her she was no sellout
right she wasn't a sellout
she
sometimes if you were liberal she didn't
always tell you always tell you what you
wanted to hear you were conservative she
didn't always tell you what you wanted
to hear sometimes
she could she could go back and forth
some of her some of her people that she
was close to some of her colleagues she
was very close with scalia who we know
was
major far right
so she didn't always it wasn't always
this pre-packaged thing you knew what
she was gonna say she didn't just go
with convenient
talking points and cliches
what am i getting at what i'm saying i'm
going somewhere with this what i'm
saying is
if you're republican
and
you're just going on party lines he's
like hey we got to do it because i'm a
republican i just got to do this i got
to push this thing through
i think i think you're i think you're
selling out you got to do what's best
for the country not what's best for your
particular party what's best for the
country is not the rush why are you
rushing why are you rushing you're
rushing because you're trying to get it
on you're right you're trying to get it
in there before the election there you
go being reasonable again
you better help it yeah you're gonna be
a reasonable again man like this is this
is this is mcconnell i can't help it
this is this this is what he's i think
he said this he should be ashamed
i mean think about it we already saw
amen
as bob knight as bob knight's bob knight
once said about a student okay we've
lost him okay we've lost mitch mcconnell
i ain't talking about him
because he is just
like
he is but now
like a lot of people
all of them know all of them lindsey
graham all of them ted cruz all of them
is like hey there's no way like you know
we're going to hold this seat for the
next president when barack obama uh you
know nominates merrick garland but hey
and not even a day later like she had
just passed away they instantly didn't
even take the time to think about it
we're pushing this through we should
confirm
we should confirm somebody before this
election so they did the same thing
they've shown themselves over and over
who they really are it was the same it
was the same thing with scalia just the
opposite
was scalia you know scalia dies and
they're like wait a minute well you know
this president should not be making any
decisions like i remember mcconnell like
scalia hadn't been dead for like you
know
it's 24 hours and there's this statement
coming out about hey you know slow down
this is not the time for nominations
then same thing friday night we see this
statement from mcconnell
going back to like oh since the 1880s no
opposite party has uh has done this
that's what i'm saying it's not about
parties not about parties it's about
your conscience if you don't have a
contract i wish you i wish you were
right whatever i don't know
you